تتابع الان من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حيث الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري
الامريكي لن تنطلق قبل فبراير المقبل لكن
الساحه بدات تزدحم بالمترشحين المحتملين
لنقل النتيجه حتى الان خمسه مترشحين عن
الحزب الجمهوري ومرشح وحيد عن الحزب
الديمقراطي هو الرئيس جو بايدن فمن هم
هؤلاء الخمسه اولهم الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب
الاوفر حظا الذي اعلن ترشحه في الخامس عشر
من نوفمبر الماضي ويعتبر الاوفر حظا اذا
الا ان احدى العقبات التي قد تواجهه هي
عدم اليقين القانوني مع تعرضه لمحاكمه في
نيويورك ولتحقيقات مستمره بولايه جورجيا
اما المرشح الثاني فهو حاكم ولايه فلوريدا
الحالي راندي سامتيس وهو ذو الشعبيه
الكبيره في اوساط الحزب الجمهوري خاصه لدى
الاطراف التي تحاول النائيه بنفسها عن
الرئيس السابق اضافه للقبول الذي يتمتع به
مع اقراره لعده مشاريع قوانين نالت رضا
القاعده الجمهوريه في فلوريدا بعد ذلك
لدينا مرشحان من سافكر ولاينا اولهما
الحاكمه السابقه للولايه والممثله السابقه
للولايات المتحده بالامم المتحده تذكرون
هذا الوجه جيدا اثناء فتره حكم ترامب
ثانيهما عضو مجلس الشيوخ تمسكت وهو العضو
الجمهوري الوحيد بالمجلس من اصول افريقيه
وعينتهيلي بصفتها حاكمه للولايه محل
سيناتور اخر من الولايه اعلن عن تقاعده في
عام 2012 لدينا ايضا مرشحون نقلت عنهم
وسائل الاعلام امريكيه نيتهم الترشح منهم
نائب الرئيس السابق مايك بانس الذي من
المتوقع ان يعلن عن ترشحه للرئاسه قريبا
وربما يتمكن من سحب جانب من مؤيدي
المرشحين الاخرين لدعمه ننتقل لاستطلاع
راي اجرته السي ان ان يوم الاربعاء من
الاسبوع الماضي اظهر ان ترامب في المرتبه
الاولى بثلاثه وخمسين في المئه بين محل
ديسانتس ثانيا فقط حصل كل من على السته
بالمئه من تفضيلات الناخبين الجمهوريين
وفقا لاستطلاع الراي ما يعني ان السباق
ربما سينحصر بين ترامب وديسانتس فقط
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات